Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Today I want to talk
to you about how
to make your users fall
in love with your apps.
I don't hear myself, so
if I shouting too much,
tell me so, OK?
Feel free, it's a conversation.
Have you ever asked yourself,
why we are so addicted,
why we are so connected
to such devices?
Why can't we take
our hands off it?
Let's put it in a different way.
How can we make our users
fall in love with applications
that we are creating.
And this is exactly what I
want to talk to you today.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about UI,
user experience, and emotions.
And then we're going to
make a deep dive into love.
We are going to talk
about human love,
and the way we are falling
in love with applications.
So stay tuned.
I'm so excited.
If you want to make a great
application, first of all,
you have to make a nice UI.
And this is what the
Android guidelines tell us.
Easy to use, and
easy to understand.
OK, here's an example.
This is from a gas
station in Israel.
I would kindly ask you to
raise your finger and point
to the screen.
Come on, don't be shy.
Point to the screen,
and dial a number
that you all very well know.
Try to dial a number.
Do that?
You simply fail.
No way that you can do this.
Why?
Because a smart guy tried
to be very smart here,
and he twisted the keypad.
So people try to press 10
to the number, the pin code,
and then they
press the Continue.
See the Continue?
It's all tiered out.
Why is that?
Because they are clicking
something, it all goes wrong,
and they do it again
and again and again.
And then they move the finger
toward the assistance button,
which is located on the
right side of the keypad.
How do I know that?
Look at the white line.
Do you see the white line
above my yellow line?
Is the path of despair.
People try, and try, and
try, and move the finger
along the keypad, and
simply fail to do this.
Now this is a really lousy UI.
You really don't
want to make such UI.
This is really bad.
If we're talking about
UX, there's experience.
If we are talking
about experience,
we're talking about emotions.
Now, how do we use our
emotions while interacting
with applications?
Back in the '90s, the
late Professor Nass,
here-- from
California, actually--
suggested a great
model named, CASA.
Remember that, Computers
As Social Agents.
What he stated was that we are
human beings treating computers
and applications
and devices just
as we're treating human beings.
That is, we tend to see humans
in the devices and applications
that we are using.
This is exactly why
applications drives you nuts
And this is why you
love applications,
and you hate applications.
Nobody love or hate
the chair, right?
You love or hate an application.
And this is the
model that he used.
And if we're talking about
the emotions, what about one
of the strongest
emotions on earth?
Love.
We are told to talk about love.
Why?
First, it is a very
important emotion.
And B, even more important
than that, we all-- designers,
and developers, and startups,
entrepreneurs-- all of us
want to create applications
that people somewhere
will love and use.
So let's have a look at love.
And this is my
talk is all about.
We are going to talk
about love, and then we'll
understand why we fall in
love with applications,
and then we'll understand
why we cheat on applications,
and so forth.
So let's start by
talking about love.
Am I speaking too
fast, as always?
Is it OK?
OK, I keep on talking too fast.
20 years as a User
Experience Designer.
I'm older than most
of you, probably.
I keep on hearing, Jacob, make
me something sexy, something
attractive, something
lovable, something
that users will like to use.
Now, is it a way of talking?
No, it isn't.
We have ancient,
subconscious mating patterns,
and we use them
toward applications.
We are falling in love
with applications.
Well, OK.
So if we want to
understand how we
fall in love with
applications, first thing to do
is to better understand how we
fall in love with each other,
as human beings.
Now there are many, many
theories regarding love.
This is an average of
many, many theories.
First of all, there is
the falling in love stage.
The first phase.
The stars are shining,
the birds are singing.
The sky's so blue,
where are you, my love?
Do you know this feeling?
This is a short,
very intensive stage.
Then comes four years of love.
Why four years?
That's life, sorry.
Because most theories assumed
that this is the time that it
takes us to get the
kid born and raise
him or her til the
stage that he or she
can place with the rest
of the kids of the tribe.
Four years, and then,
unfortunately-- or fortunately,
it's by the eye
of the beholder--
there's a loss of interest.
This is love.
Enough with love, let's
talk about application.
OK, Draw Something.
Anybody play Draw
Something around here?
Yes.
Anybody's playing
Draw Something now?
Hm.
Let's look at Draw
Something statistics.
It started as a discovery.
Then it went on to
long-term usage.
Needless to say, much
shorter than four years.
It was almost four months.
But it was a plateau, and
then, lost of interest.
Look familiar to you?
Yes it does, and it should.
Why?
Because we are subconsciously
falling in love
with applications we use.
And if you will
understand that, you
will better know how
to design applications.
Now, since I know that
you don't believe me,
let's address a more
credible source.
MTV Networks made a big
research a few years ago.
How do we engage
with applications?
Guess what they found?
They found that there are
four stages-- the discovery,
and then the adoption, and
then the trial that you try,
and then you decide
if you keep it or not.
This is exactly the path
of love, completely.
So here's my tip.
Think about love
when you design.
Here's something that you, I'm
sure that when you attended
I/O, you didn't think that
you were going to hear.
Each of you is working, let's
say, on an application, or part
of an application,
or model, or so.
Try to think about
the project that you
are working right
now as human being.
Call him-- give
it a name, and try
to think, what will make
other people love this person?
Again, think about
the application
that you are working
now as a human being,
and try to think what
will make people love it.
You'll be suprised.
So we know about now
that we are falling
in love with applications.
And we know about
now that hopefully we
are using it subconsciously.
So here's a great question.
What makes us fall in love
with a certain person?
As you understand the
logic of this talk by now,
I always start talking
about human beings,
and then switch to applications.
So here are results
of a 20,000 people--
men, actually-- survey in
Yotango, which were asked,
what attracts you?
As simple as that.
And here goes the data.
First of all, sexual chemistry.
God knows what it is,
but it's something
has to do with sexual chemistry.
And then comes the
smile, then the kindness,
then sense of humor.
Fifth list general body type.
Love this one, general
body type, probably the way
she looks.
And then the eyes, and
then the intelligence.
Then communication skills, teeth
and lips, and finally, hair.
And I keep telling my
wife, invest your time
in improving your smile,
not making up your hair.
But she don't listen to me.
So this is what happens
when you fall in love.
This is what attracts men.
Three months later,
here are the results.
It's changing.
For example, sexual chemistry
drops from the first place
to the fourth place.
Smile goes to the sixth place.
Kindness, surprise,
surprise, first place.
And sense of humor,
second place.
Anybody can predict
what will be the next.
Very simple, it's written on
the board, communication skills.
From eighth place to the
third place, surprising.
This is the picture
of how it looks.
Now there's something
really serious, here.
You have to think about
what attracts human beings
to human beings when you
design applications, right.
You have to think
about it not only
during the launch
of the application,
but a few months later.
And we're going to get back
to that very, very soon.
But let's get back to
the first impression.
I have marked in
red a few items.
It's the smile.
It's the general body
type, it's the eyes,
it's the teeth and
lips, and it's the hair.
Why is that?
All of them has in common
one thing, they are visual.
Five out of ten characteristics
which actually drives
our attention while getting
attracted to a person
are visual.
Therefore, when you
design an application,
you have to think about the
visuals very, very carefully.
Now if I would tell you, make
great looking applications,
it's like telling you nothing.
You have to know what to do.
So, back to the 17th century.
Really.
17th century, the golden
ratio was presented.
That is, if we have a picture
with distinguished area
inside it, the ratio between
the length and the size
of the areas will determine if
it will perceived as beautiful
or not.
And these are the
correct ratios.
Here is an example.
Let's turn it, and
let's see this picture.
Recognize this lady?
The Mona Lisa.
She is not the most
beautiful woman on earth.
She is not sex machine.
But when you see
this picture, people
can't move their eyes off it.
Why?
I guess that you've
guessed by now.
Because she completely,
exactly, obey the golden ratio.
Now let's turn into a more ugly
face, also known as me, OK.
So this is Google+,
sorry, here's Google+,
and you can see the
upper section, here.
And surprise, surprise,
surprise, golden ratio
works here, just almost perfect.
A little tip to Google, just
make this part of the screen,
this picture, a little bit
wider, and you're perfect.
But it's almost there.
This is why we are
attracted to that.
So here's my tip-- create
beautiful interfaces.
Forget it, never mind.
I thought that you will be
finding some [INAUDIBLE]
there, but OK.
Always question jokes.
OK, just a short reminder.
We are using subconscious
mating patterns.
Therefore, a short
question-- what is this?
It's Google Play?
Forget about it, it's a bar.
It's a bar full of
beautiful people.
When you get into
a bar, and you want
to talk to someone tonight,
have beer, talk, and chat,
and so forth, you have lots
of faces that you don't know.
And you have to think, or
select somebody to talk to.
This is exactly
what happens here.
Actually, I have compared the
top 100 apps in Google Play
to the lower 100 of
the top of the line.
And it can be easily
observed that the graphics
are completely different, OK.
If I may say so, you
don't get a second chance
for first impression.
Now, I'm in the same
industry as you are.
And we are talking about
clean startups, and lean UX,
and agile development,
and so forth.
And show seekers.
But, keep in mind-- invest
the minimum in graphics,
otherwise people won't
love your applications.
We spoke about the way it looks.
Now here, let's have a
deeper look about moves.
Now it you're talking look,
talking about materials,
there's a nice guideline,
presented only yesterday.
Try to read it.
And we are talking
about the physics
of the animations [INAUDIBLE].
It should as a
mass, and it should
obey to the law of gravity, and
law of physics, and so forth.
But I want to add
something else.
Let's talk about dance.
I know you didn't
expect it, it's OK.
Dr. Nick Neave, from the
UK, made a very interesting
research.
He took videos of three,
four, five men, dancing.
Then he presented
these men to women
and asked them to evaluate
how attractive these men are,
on a scale kind of 1 to 9.
That's very easy to do.
Now, in addition, he took
blood tests from these men.
It's looking for genetical
mutation, that is, how
genetically wise,
healthy, are they?
And surprise,
surprise, the men that
were evaluated as
the more attractive,
according to their
dance were those
who had to the little
genetical mutation.
Put it in a different way.
When a woman see
a man dancing, she
can tell by the
way you dance, what
would be the quality of the
genes that you can supply her.
Sounds weird, but
it's completely true.
And it doesn't work vice versa.
That is, when a man
see a woman dancing,
he can tell nothing about
the quality of the genes.
It was tested.
Really, I'm not kidding.
Now what does it
have to do with us?
It has a lot to do with us.
Women are attracted to the
healthier men by their dance.
Now, what is a good dance?
He checked that, and there
are three major factors.
1, it should be symmetrical.
B, it should be smooth.
And 3, it should involve
body core movement,
that is the torso, and so forth.
Now, try to look at
animations that you know.
All great animations show
the exact movement patterns
as great dancers.
Why is that?
Remember the CASA, remember the
theory that I presented before?
We are using subconscious
mating patterns.
And this is exactly
what happens here.
When we see an animation
dance, we actually
see a man or a woman dancing.
And we are attracted
to this animation
because it is a good dance.
This is why good animation
never flips this way.
Because you can't
dance this way.
But animations do flip this way.
That was a lousy
dance by me, sorry.
But you know what I mean.
And this is why animation goes
down, because there's gravity,
and it goes up.
So here is my
little tip for you.
When you are alone
in your room-- alone,
let me emphasize this
point-- get off your chair
and dance the animation
that you have just designed.
If you can dance the animation
that you have just created,
perfect animation.
If it looks something like this,
back to the drawing board, OK.
I'm really serious.
That's the tragic of my life, I
real serious, and people laugh.
No, I'm just kidding, it's OK.
So think of animation
as a dancer.
And since I have
only two minutes,
I want to talk to you,
last but not least,
about how can we
keep love going on?
A short reminder--
we all start here,
and then unfortunately,
we are going here.
And this is exactly
the stage when
you as an entrepreneur, or a
software developer, or company
owner, say, oh, they don't
love my application anymore,
they don't like it.
How can we keep our vows?
OK, you know the system by now.
If we want to better understand
how to keep the vows,
we have to better
understand what
happens in our interpersonal
relationship, how loyal are we?
And we are not that loyal.
Actually, when you
ask people, why
do you leave the applications?
About half of them will
say, because there's
nothing new over there.
No new content, no new
interaction, no new visuals,
nothing new.
So I'm getting bored.
It's not interesting anymore.
It's just the same as
many divorced couples
say, people who want to divorce.
She's boring.
I know exactly what my husband
is going to say, and so forth.
Read some marriage consulting
papers, you'll find it.
So what is the
advice to avoid this?
Very simple.
Make it look a little
different, from time to time.
That is, in a sense
you can take the graph
from this point
back to the love.
Now since it sounds very
vague, here is an example.
How many times was Gmail changed
during the last few years?
Let's look at the Android,
it started in 2010,
and then Gingerbread '11,
and then Ice Cream Sandwich,
and then Jelly Bean,
and then KitKat.
You can easily see that this is
the same family of interaction.
This the same family
of graphic design.
It's just as if me in my
first days of my marriage,
the second day of
my marriage I find
something new to
surprise my wife.
And so forth, and so forth.
And this is something
that you want to do.
You should and want to supply
constant minor changes.
Even though there's no
technical or UI need for that.
Keep on surprising your users.
But keep in mind, don't
make too big surprise.
Otherwise, the guy you were just
married is changed completely,
and we don't want to
live with this guy.
I really want to
thank you for being
with me at the last session.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.